I'm Trevor Blackwell CEO of any bots
we're a Silicon Valley company with a
mission to change the way people work
together over distances it's so
important to be part of the team at the
office we want to give people a way of
interacting with people and really being
part of a remote team without having to
fly it's like a video conference system
but you can drive it around so it goes
where you tell it to you can be similar
instantly if an issue comes up in the
factory or the warehouse you can be
there in seconds it's designed to feel
smooth comfortable and safe when someone
logs into it it announces itself it
moves when you tell it to via the
keyboard it's useful for anyone who
needs to work with other people across
town or across the world I really care
about making people be part of the team
they're in